main cultural icon all sorts of stories
get printed about you so last week
Warren Beatty's here and we did this
thing with him where we just read out
some of the Mads stories that have been
in the papers about him over the years
this could be fun and we just kind of
read your expression there will be a
camera very close on your face I read
these out we'll just try and gauge from
your face you're young your face moves
so let's see are you ready for this the
Warren Beatty
deadpan challenge you took a carrot cake
to a Fleetwood Mac concert that's yes
take a carrot cake the food I like
carrot cake and Fleetwood Mac hopefully
love you and Liam got comitia from a
koala girl
but confirm that's not true okay you
were thinking of becoming in a state
agent okay set your face for this one I
really want to see this one okay okay
you had a sexual relationship with
Barack Obama wavering you keep your skin
and check the sheep placenta that's not
true okay fair enough
finally you auditioned to be the new Han
Solo that would be a yes and yet
afterwards where they felt about
upstaged by Zayn's hair now how do you
planned the loose strand no it kind of
just fell that way yeah I mean it looks
it looks lovely it works but if
Twittersphere meltdown this hair here's
just a selection of some of the tweets
that they say in single strand of hair
it's prettier than my entire
we haven't seen the person it could be
true it's another one Saenz hair is the
reason I love this saying tonight is why
I still this this is devious this year
someone was just so moved
all they could eat was this
[Applause]
died on his shoulder back to Ireland
much is that I do cause a huge sensation
when you go back it's a Mullingar yeah
wanna go yeah yeah I go home like a
couple of times a year I get my dad's
that lives in the same spot and so it
gets kind of hectic around the house the
girls live in holes in the garden and
things yeah remember Robbie Williams
once said something to me he's like my
mum closed the curtains in 92 and never
opened them again like it's good I get
to go home and you know good seed lads
and stuff like that and see the family
and it's yeah I like that side of it but
yet miss Ireland obviously we'd like to
go there a lot more about and do people
kind of do they look out for you kind of
going oh he's changed or is that all
that do you have to be incredibly
careful when you go home sometimes like
you've been there and you'd be like as
there's kind of like back I can tell you
know you'll be buying like a pint you
know be buying a pint for two or three
lads and then you know the barman to be
gone Oh someone's doing all right in a
he's doing good it's like so many few
pints yeah like sometimes if I can walk
at home right I'll walk home if they're
just safe home around Christmas and
there's no taxis and I would start
walking home and then the police will
walk right past me and pick me up bring
me home do you see that for a different
reason
listen before we do anything else we
must all say a huge congratulations to
Liam new daddy you and Cheryl have a
baby yes and you were there at the birth
you were there at the birth definitely
yes I was there at the birth and it was
a it was a make it was the most amazing
thing and then I was left with bear
after after she gave birth and she fell
asleep and then I'd never changed nappy
before until I met bear so I was like I
can do this so I spent the whole day
doing the nappy change in business now I
was getting along with it just fine it
was going great admin we done we struck
a deal early doors and then five o'clock
in the morning a bear woke up and my
missus was like honey I'll do it I'll do
this one so I was that cool yo pick over
bear
it's his first nappy change she brought
in Ron bales a nappy food first time
it's happened and then he starts
sprouting off we like a meaningful music
and slow-mo going on everything yeah it
was I think it was very ironic after she
did build the hard work I said we took a
deal any bills it was okay I like that
music and but actually very quickly
before we say nothing
I should just saying if you are a Zayn
Malik fan I'm really sorry and he's not
here
I'm out of here Ryan was upset what yeah
no I saw with your tweets hurt
Zayn Malik's really making me regret
this day and Malik tattoo have a lot
back Ryan treated when he heard the news
of the cancellation Zayn is not a grave
norton show with me anymore I'll still
go but obviously I got my lips done for
nothing
obviously you're a fan of the One
Direction I can see but as One Direction
met Ian McKellen as Ian we have what one
direction before oh I thought you'd have
a bigger beard didn't you come close to
meeting in New Zealand we did yeah we
were on tour in London and they were
filming yes and you were meant to come
and see us filming yeah the day after
your final concert so I thought I'd go
and have a look at them over they are
very enjoyable thank you I think a small
show I mean it was just you know no
fireworks or anything but and a quite a
small theatre to remember anyway they
didn't turn up the next day to visit us
because why I don't know yeah your plane
might have been moved earlier or
something
now in the comics I saw the pictures of
you all at the premiere on Monday night
oh yeah and I mean it's been part of
your life for nigh on 14 years now so
what's that an emotional night or where
the emotions happened already
yeah well it's over you know we're not
we've not been working on The Hobbit for
some time now but it was very moving I
mean you go and these kids have been
sleeping out all night what do you know
about this but these people would not
born when we started making Lord of the
Rings No so it's a big part of their
lives and that's that's very sweet isn't
it and they'll be able to see all six
movies now and show them to their kids
that's what's nice we've made classic
and also it will take nearly a day to
watch it yeah I was off school L once I
think I did I'm with my friend
[Applause]
you